last time we were binary searching we
were binary searching last time what we
searching for this week we're still
binary searching but we're going to
binary search ever so slightly better
than we did before that's the idea so it
was pointed out into comments to me that
under some you know languages and
computational architectures there'd be a
bug in the binary search code that I
wrote now I mean I would I would like
the record to show that there isn't a
bug in my code obviously uh mostly
because I programmed it in Python um and
python has a slightly different way of
dealing with numbers but let's look at
this bug because actually this was quite
a serous problem this existed in Java
for example for about 9 years nearly
nearly a decade this bug was there which
would have thrown errors in a certain
set set of circumstances where this
binary search that you program that
makes absolute sense doesn't actually do
what you think it does under some
circumstances it's an edge case that you
haven't spotted right there are always
going to be things like this so there's
a much safer way to code it where you
can get around this problem but this
happens a lot with code you write your
code you do a lot of tests everything
works fine you just didn't test those
exact set of circumstances that caused
the bug to appear right so actually one
of the phrases you see a lot is recreate
the bug right which is what where when
someone reports there's a bug to you if
you can recreate it that's the first
step in finding it so let's REM remind
ourselves what we were up to we we had
some boxes which I'm going to draw again
but we're not going to spend too much
time talking about binary search this
time we're just going to talk about the
way we calculate which box to open next
so if you remember
we have some variables in our binary
search that represent where we are
currently looking right so at the
beginning we have our left point over on
the at start of your array and the right
point at the right hand side of your
array and then later maybe you've
decided it's only in this section so you
have your midpoint somewhere over here
right so let's suppose we have our left
Point here and our right point up here
what we need to do is calculate our
midpoint and we do that so that we can
decide work okay we're probably going to
open this box box we open this box and
decide which side then we need to look
on or maybe we found our number so the
formula we used for this was m is equal
to l + r / 2 right and then what we did
was we did the floor function which says
the nearest integer below this now in
Python this will always work because in
python as far as I know in Python we
don't have the same restrictions as we
do in some other languages where numbers
are a fixed size but as mentioned in the
comments quite reasonably
uh in the last video there are certain
circumstances where this will fail right
and that's because what we're doing is
we're doing this very large intermediate
sum between the left and the right and
then dividing by two which basically
means that temporarily our number gets
very large and then it gets reduced back
down into correct range so what this
should do is give us an N value of l+ R
/ 2 which will be the average which is M
right here but imagine your data is
let's say one or two billion elements in
length which doesn't happen to me very
often but it does happen sometimes um
and it would be much more common if you
were working for a large organization
that had a huge amount of data now let's
imagine that each of these numbers is
over about 1.2 billion or something like
that so the theoretical maximum size of
an array in Java is about um 2.1 billion
elements roughly speaking that's the
maximum size of of a signed integer and
if we have if we're looking up at the
top end of this array then our L and R
values are going to be close to that
value when we add them together they're
going to overflow over the maximum
integer size so if if L plus r is over
this value of 2.1 billion you'll get
what we call an integer overflow where
your integer becomes so big but it wraps
back around and you get a very very
large minus number because of two
complement perhaps the most easy one to
understand is that yes if you add
together two positive numbers that are
too big they're going to come out
looking like a negative number right now
if you try and index your array at M
where m is a hugely minus number you're
going to get an error right and out of
bounds exception and your um your code
is going to crash so if you don't ever
have that situation then this will never
come up right and that doesn't mean
necessarily that you should always just
use this code but it's worth noting that
you might have a set of circumstances
where 1 billion is way out of the range
that your program would ever produce in
which case this is not really a big deal
and this is probably why it didn't get
spotted for many years because it just
didn't come up very often right and then
when it when it was eventually when it
was eventually found it found there was
textbooks that were wrong j was wrong
huge implementations were wrong because
there's not really anything wrong with
this it just doesn't work because of the
the restrictions on introduced so what
would be a better way of doing it what
we were originally doing was L + r / 2
so if you had um an L that was here like
this and a and a bigger R because your R
is over on the right hand side over here
what you will be doing is putting this
here adding together and taking the
midpoint which would be somewhere sort
of here right that's that's kind of the
idea that's your average but yeah if you
put that there it' probably run off the
end runs off the end of the screen and
we've got our overflow and then we're
all way over here on the yeah exactly
right so you know the paper works we
should stick with it what we're going to
do instead is we're going to do R minus
L right R minus l so what would that be
that would be the difference between R
minus L here I could probably drawn it
over here so then what you do is what
half of that and then add it to the L
exactly right so we divide this by two
to get this bit here right and then we
add the original L back again so this is
r - L / 2 and then we add back L right
I'm not sure if drawing it out like this
worked but hopefully that makes so it's
a slightly more complicated sum but
hopefully it keeps us in bounds right
yeah so what we've done is we it keeps
us in bounds because we've never R is
always bigger than l in our in our
binary search or they might be the same
in which case that's the last step but
essentially R minus L is never going to
be a negative number and it's never
going to overflow over the end of a
32-bit integer right and that avoids
this problem okay so I actually uh
implemented this in Java and we can
actually see it crash and then we can
fix it right okay so I just recreated my
python code in Java because I wanted to
recreate the bug and in Python it has
arbitrary size integers which means that
basically when your integer becomes 33
bits it doesn't wrap around it's just 33
bits from then on right now that has a
performance hit but it's not much for
for normal use and uh so that's a good
way to program in some ways but actually
I quite like the restrictions sometimes
and for example in things like
cryptography it's very important that
your data is always the exact size that
they're expecting because otherwise the
mathematics won't do the same thing at
all right and so actually for encryption
algorithms it's always very very strict
about exactly how big your data is at
any given time now so I've created
binary search again so we can see the
same algs we had before and here is our
offending line so I'm going to say bad
that's not that's a python comment not a
Java comment excuse me right so this is
bad right and it's bad
because theoretically if we have very
large indices left and right our
midpoint will our intermediates on will
overflow so I'm going to create an array
of a len of length 1.2 billion which is
long enough that we're going to overflow
if we're near the end of it right
because the left and right values added
together will be larger than the biggest
size of ingry we can handle someone
pointed out in the comments very wisely
that why not just create an array of
consecutive numbers from one up to the
length of the array well one to be
really clever and smart about it sure or
we can wait here for 10 minutes while we
drink coffee because it's sorting
algorithm takes ages fine I take your
point so what I'm doing here is I'm
creating an array of length 1.2 billion
I'm then just going to make every
element in the array its own Index right
so essentially the first number will be
not the next number will be one all the
way up to 199 million no anyway uh yeah
1 billion 100 anyway so on so if we run
this and you'll want to skip through the
build process you'll find that there is
no error right uh because there's
nothing wrong with creating an array of
this size so if I output binary search
of let's say using our array and we're
going to search for the number 17 which
we know is in the array because uh 17
again I don't think there's any real
actual significance of the number 17 um
so if we run this what should happen is
it prints out true because we can find a
number and
it does right good now so suppose we
remove 17 from the the array so all I'm
going to do is in front of this line I'm
going to say array at 17 is going to be
16 right so what I'm doing there is just
saying there's going to be two 16s in a
row which is not ideal but it will be
fine if there's no longer a 17 in the
array this should return false cut to
the bit where it says false false right
so it's working so our binary search is
working now what would have happened is
someone implemented this based on some
textbook it works fine they cons
considered their job done for the day
and they went home right and then 9
years later someone goes a second right
so let's now look at what happens when
we're not looking for 17 we're looking
at a number right at the far other side
of the array where the numbers get much
bigger okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say okay do a binary search
for the number 1 billion 190 million and
let's say uh 17 oh yeah all right
is that the right length of number we
will soon find out so I'm going to run
that and we'll see what
happens right we've got an exception
which is kind of funny enough what I
wanted to happen so our index of minus a
billion and something is out of bounds
for this array which is obviously out of
bounds because it doesn't allow negative
indices so why is that happened well
what happened was at some point we were
looking at this far end of the array and
L and R added up to be a number more
than
1.2 billion so now let's fix our code
and see if we can do a bit better so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this line away good and we're going
to say okay we're going to do L plus
half a difference between them right
which is still the same exact result but
we haven't had to add them together so
we can do right minus left / two okay
like that and that should perform
exactly the same it should find 17 it
should not find 17 it should find this
number but hopefully won't crash this
time
true it found it and if we take that
number away we should get a false so if
we say array of I'm going to copy it
because I don't think I can type that a
second time there we go something like
that right this allows us to keep the
them in consecutive order this should
return
false there we go so the binary search
now works but it also works for any
numbers in your array even if your array
is up to the maximum size that Java
allows right which is which is nice
right now if you actually look at the
Java source code you'll find that this
this bug has been fixed as of about 2006
something like that so it was seen quite
a while ago but this bug did exist for
quite a long
time shouldn't just use it all the time
you use it when you're doing more
lookups than you are sorting right so if
you you know maybe you sort your data at
the beginning of a day you may want to
come up with a new one and say should
this belong to group one or group two so
before actually going there and then
doing this synthesizer of them could I